frisch vom grill oder gut geräuchert die
deutschen lieben es fleisch zu essen und
sie tun es ausgiebig für die meisten
eine selbstverständlichkeit fleisches zu
unseren lebensmitteln
immer so
durchschnittlich fast 60 kilogramm
fleisch pro jahr isst jeder bundesbürger
und liegt damit deutlich über dem
schnitt aller erdenbewohner und doch es
bewegt sich was im land der currywürste
zu sehen zum beispiel hier auf dem
freiburger wochenmarkt zwischen all den
wurst und schinken ständen steht dieser
grüne wagen würstchen hier sehen ein
bisschen eckige aus und die salatbeilage
üppiger er ist hier aus professionellen
gründen er kümmert sich um den vertrieb
des tv herstellers
ich glaube schon dass es ein allgemeiner
trend ist eigentlich ein megatrend klein
space also es beschäftigt schon immer
mehr menschen auch gerade viele junge
menschen manche sprechen von dem kreta
effekt also viele hinterfragen ihr
konsumverhalten unter sehen da eben in
pflanzlichen proteinen auch eine große
chance und wir merken dass natürlich
auch am auto vor hunger dadurch steigt
die ganz konsequenten die veganer sind
mit einem prozent immer noch selten aber
der anteil der vegetarier in deutschland
liegt je nach statistik bei sechs bis
zehn prozent den großen effekt aber hat
dieses drittel der bevölkerung es sagt
den umfragen sich künftig fleisch
annähern zu wollen
eine neue zielgruppe die auch bürger
ketten in bewegung bringt mcdonald zum
beispiel mit seinen weltweit mehr als
37.000 filialen startete in deutschland
sein neues produkt neben den 40.000
tonnen fleisch die die kette allein in
deutschland jedes jahr verarbeitet gibt
es seit 2009 10 auch dies einen veganen
bürger im standardsortiment
zitiert wird der getrennt von allen
fleischprodukten so kann der bürger
offiziell als vegan beworben werden
das ist ein perry auf soja weizen basis
das eben sehr sehr fleisch ähnlich
aussieht und eben vor allem auch relativ
fleisch ähnlich schmeckt sie hätten sie
auch schon zumachen können wenn die
gäste zehn jahre früher das nachgefragte
hätten das auch schon früher acuña
fleisch das keines ist jetzt scheint die
zeit reif dafür
und das verhilft ihr zu einer neuen
bedeutung der sojabohne proteinreiche
bisher hauptsächlich an tiere verfüttert
aber viel effizienter lässt sie sich für
menschliche nahrung nutzen
hier werden die boden vermahlen erhitzt
gepresst
das ergebnis eine masse die sich
beliebig formen und würzen lässt
den anfängen unserer vier mal haben wir
sehr wohl einige würstchen tofu
bürstchen entwickelt damit die menschen
eine anknüpfung haben damit sie eine
assoziation haben das kennen sie schon
und dann fällt ihnen leichter dazu
wechseln
aber für uns ist ganz wichtig dass wir
heute lebensmittel entwickeln die in der
eigenständigkeit haben muss ein pflanzen
produkt wie fleisch aussehen
es ist die alte diskussion der
vegetarier szene aus ihr entstand vor
rund 30 jahren die firma typhoon tofu
100 tonnen produziert das unternehmen
pro woche weniger als die firma
verkaufen könnte im aktuellen tofo boom
doch die bio zertifizierung aller
zutaten ist langwierig und im
familienunternehmen gibt es immer noch
viel handarbeit tofu in deutschland war
lange ein nischenprodukt andere regionen
sind weiter asien ist sozusagen das das
mutterland man könnte auch sagen der
mutter kontinent für diverse
sojaprodukte
da ist nur eines von vielen das wird
dort ganz selbstverständlich gegessen
seit vielen jahrhunderten schon das hat
auch den status eines
grundnahrungsmittels wird aber auch ganz
selbstverständlich mit tierischen
produkten kombiniert so hoch und fisch
oder rindfleisch ist in arzfeld
verständlich dummerweise gibt es immer
mehr fleisch zum tofu in china zum
beispiel zeigt sich deutlich der
zusammenhang von fleischkonsum und
wirtschaftswachstum
je mehr geld verdient wird desto mehr
fleisch kommt auf den teller
inzwischen haben die chinesen die
deutschen beim pro-kopf-verbrauch
überholt
die deutschen schweinezüchter
exportieren ihre überschüsse nach china
denn in deutschland gibt es immer mehr
so genannte flexitarier
einmal die woche vielleicht zwei mal
aber nicht
mehr ist auch nicht gesund für den
menschlichen körper und für das klima
sowieso